when do you roll the beautiful bean
footage the path did you go the same
place with us no I knew what it was they
did and see Bush's baked beans they had
this talking dog he knew the family
recipe we all they knew the family
wouldn't ruin it yeah but this goddamn
dog nobody gonna do the welcome he was
offering to sell it all the time a crazy
dog it's probably he's probably dead
yeah yeah I judge Greg mother hey
actually what's coming on Oh way better
this is what it's all about it's a video
game history month yeah and we thought
what better excuse to get you in here
you just stay in the road hi Jan is
right down the road or blame Brandon
right in front of Merrigan sub shop oh
hey their subs knew about it yeah are
you in their pocket I'm trying to be
known as well as I want I come in
sometimes they're like oh hey Greg I'm
like no I want the free sandwich don't
know my name that's not good enough that
was worth about two weeks of thing I
better be come on I'm trying here no
mayo I'm not there no mayo come on you
gotta do something special for that yeah
exact a to ya anti-male crowd over yeah
man alright that's demonstrable fall
before we talk before we play this
wonderful game that you've brought in
sure yeah I want to talk to you about
some viewing so oh good that's what I do
for a living it is I've heard that it's
not just what you do you also review
Oreos on YouTube yeah sure podcast about
regular nerd culture right stuff right I
believe yours but IGN signs the checks
that's where I talk about games what are
we talking about III oh my goodness when
you excited for we're like it to be over
no I'm excited to go there and find out
new stuff stuff we don't know about
right that's the big thing like right
now it's like okay cool like it's you
look down the line like we have these
new next-gen systems and everything's
cool and super HD and why others Batman
come in and one day we'll the order and
the DOTA and it's like okay but like
what what is really happening right now
you know I mean transistors awesome and
I love having that it's really cool that
the last of us is coming to ps4 yeah but
what's like the big announcement when
the lights go out for the Xbox
conference and they come up what are
they gonna show on the screen stuff like
that what have you been playing so far
editor to new consoles like mostly lot
of mario golf a lot of mario golf
weren't world to around 80 hours in
right now there's a lot of our video I'm
over 80 hours now for sure more than 80
hours sunk into mario golf world tour
it's really good if you like mario golf
i think i played one
yeah for fans of mario golf for fans of
mine and we were grading on the curve
here okay mario golf fans we were
talking about great Mario sports games
yeah and did you play Meyer strikers
charged a little bit i didn't get into
it like other people sorry i got a TI
rosemount bad boy see that's that's cuz
you're from across the pond that's right
route that's big deal over there higher
soccer yeah well say he's like our he's
like our face of soccer in a in Europe
really yeah what he said Talia yeah okay
hmm what have I been playing a lot on
the new systems yes I played a lot of
titanfall i put in 30 hours titanfall i
haven't touched the new maps yet they
look cool i'm excited for what I saw
there of course DC Universe Online the
best MMO of all time I put in another
couple when dozen hours there recently
though I started Wolfenstein last night
excited get deeper in that I like
transistor a lot big fan so beautiful
yes Oh beautiful I'm nah they do it
anomaly keep making these games that are
so beautiful and sound so good this
gorgeous yeah Oh idea they're just based
on the road as well yeah we're talk--i
we're in the hotbed of the video game
community like yeah you talked about a
Nintendo game there what do you think
about Nintendo going into III because
more and more the conversations seem to
be we're talking microsoft sony right
I'm Nintendo's of this is some people
have written off the new console
completely sure people saying
concentrate on 3d stuff how do you feel
about why we're in a tender war at the
moment I mean I feel like they're
exactly where Nintendo always is there's
nothing you know I mean they've been
telling the same story forever and we
always think it's gonna change in like
the wii was the big one right they
caught fire so it looked like it was
different but in reality was the same
thing of third parties not really
supporting this thing with things that
the core gamer wants but I own my
Nintendo for the exclusives right I own
it for the Zelda I own it for the mario
golf as you know and I know Mario's and
some other things here but now I I mean
I coming out of III or coming into III i
should say with Nintendo this year it's
like a what are gonna show me what do
you what do you got the Zelda it would
be the next one right kids like gazelle
what Zelda can't wait another year to
show it yeah we use el de yeah we got to
see what this fun the final HD fully
from the ground up none of this debt
tech demo nonsense yeah exactly i am
come up with so if nintendo came out and
showed a bunch of really good first
party stuff and there wasn't that much
they're probably sport you'd be your
kind of cool with that oiler alert
that's what's gonna happen okay that is
you just saw did they show you the
Nintendo Direct early
yeah that's exactly I mean I you know I
have the wii u mainly for smash most
importantly for carp so I've got what I
want out of that system I didn't buy it
with the a thing of like well here's my
definitive Assassin's Creed meshia all
right here's where i'm only gonna play
my bet look at my second screen watchdog
right okay so yeah I expect to come out
and do that what they always do show
some cute games that are gonna be cool
cool when enough about new constant this
new crap let's talk about classic
console classic game this is actually
Jeff Grossman's machine yet Jeff
Gerstmann machine Edition sega master
system you might have heard of it it is
the defense sorry but that's all right
that's all I thanks Ian show that
controller oh look at this look at that
thing thanks for dropping that off in
Japan one button and the two button of
course cuz you one button doubles as a
start button hey be what that was stolen
we couldn't you kind of do that so yeah
you asked me to come in I did I asked
you to come in I asked you to bring a
game that was important to you in your
childhood right the game that like got
you passionate about video of course so
so of course I brought in Sega Master
System assay kit I'm running
ghostbusters huh look at that one
Ghostbuster there any megachords omega
cartridge now it's great because on the
back there's just a completely bat-crap
insane description of ghostbusters oh
yeah that makes a little noise daddy so
if you're tired of your regular old job
why not sign it as a ghostbuster and
find out what a real job is they didn't
say anything about being a scientist
busting makes me feel good no literally
somebody was just like given the the
spec script for what Ghostbusters was
like walls of rice and Stephen thing
about it a real job yeah I like being a
teacher yeah whatever your sicky your
old job also here's my one that and best
of all if you're lucky you'll meet face
to face with the ghost leader of the
universe Gore's ax no I can fight hope I
hope not not no sirs the the villain
from the movie gorzan orsa he he is the
big one you should be looking out from a
different era dog this is this a Beverly
Hills cough game where they didn't have
license to like the actual store no
that's just the title and the logo
what's so crazy about the Ghostbusters
game is that it's actually good it's
actually a decent representation other
than the fact that the actor ones like
the worst car in the game which is
stupid but I mean it's your one
seen on the screen your dryer and doing
all the stuff you're driving the ecto-1
there it is you got this thing it's in
kilometers so you're right at home well
not anymore well known I years my god no
convert yet no we would know we were Moz
narrow and in Europe got involved yeah
your works what are you gonna do but no
yeah you mean you wanted a game that
like define me I would not be here
without ghostbusters the video game
saved your life it did well no you've
got multiple persons I do well to see
the itis is actually signed by David
Craig it is i have my my Atari cartridge
signed by David Crane the program run
Ghostbuster creator of a pitfall and
right yeah that his lesser-known game
he's more known for Ghost Busters on the
course but now so the story goes like
this all right is that I was believe it
or not a Ghostbusters fan growing up
it's my first piece of real fandom
outside of comic books I needed to grow
up and get a little bit outside of the
comic book so I went into the
Ghostbusters of course they're
scientists yeah natural step in
evolution any juice right and so
obsessed with Ghostbusters bottle my mom
bought me all this was but mom dad
bought twist so one day they made the
mistake of taking me toys r us okay they
went down the video game aisle or and I
did not know what a video game was this
point I'm pre-kindergarten at this this
day and age and I'm walking walking
walking behind the glass remember the
old toys r us they got the cartridge
yeah okay glad out in frying other they
can and i was walking i'll put it here
i'll do the fact i was like one dumb kid
warm up and then i got a corner of my
eye I see the Ghostbusters leg on it's
like and I'm just boom finger to the
glass and like that's what I want for my
birthday my mom and my moms like that is
a video game like what is that and then
we had like a 10 minute conversation
there about what constituted the video
game did she have to get the consult in
and everything oh yeah nice oh yeah that
was the thing I they broke up the gifts
cuz they were smart like Uncle Mike I
believe got me the game mom and dad got
me the console for their knockoff duck
hunt that came with it and so yeah I
like that like if it wasn't for my love
of ghostbusters who knows when I would
have got into video games yeah I could
have been athletic and into sports and
God forbid that anything could happen
you could have walked by there's a
Ghostbusters branded baseball back yeah
I'll be right thanks good Ghostbusters
brinded polled and bro is less Ripper
like just anything like how you all sure
going fisherman with that Danny I'm not
gonna lie i like how you
jumped to me being the thing I I saw a
video game I don't make the games I mean
I'd be reviewing strippers already why
you're about baseball was how it worked
well own imagination got carried away
that was a stirring origin story Yeah
right and so yeah years later David
Crane was in the office and they're like
are we need you interview Mike great and
I went through his page Mike who's this
old guy pitfall sucks and i'm looking
through and i found out that he made the
Ghostbusters game so I had this
cartridge for the Atari version from one
and only craig harris i ran in so I I
saved it my pocket this is a great
moment that you can catch on IGN com
where I allow it I said it you see it's
probably easier Scott YouTube dave mcrae
naija uh he sat down we're sitting there
talking and I did that whole story I
just told you I'm like by the way you
created me I told the whole story and I
whipped out the cartridge and had him
sign it and he you didn't seem as
impressed with it as I hope oh really I
thought you'd be like oh man I got your
Ma's what idiot but now he's like all
right let's go full circle okay connect
it back up oh I also brought ghost house
is an honorable mention cuz everybody
loved the story of Mick tell us I don't
know I don't know ghost houses never say
you hard-hearted is the Sega card this
is how ahead of the time the sega master
system is it accepted two forms of media
to thank you to use big fat cartridge or
you could be the happening kid with the
credit card looking car and should be
like and you have you got it right here
you sorry we don't take American Express
sir well do you take the Sega card and
then you put it in they be like no
that's still not earlier do it there you
go I'll read you a little bit about
ghost house though because this is even
this is even worse than the Ghostbusters
one at some point but but you've
basically your name Mick you've been
left a house you have to go through and
get it even left a haunted house the bad
news is that they're hidden inside count
Dracula's mansion they have been for
years first you have to wipe wipe out
the bats Dracula's and eventually
they're ignoring annoying henchmen it's
count Dracula's mansion and you just
said he was a singular Dracula and now
there's Dracula's but even wars in
lowercase D at least no it's never
better and then eventually they're
annoying instrument like the annoying
henchmen or worse than
all Dracula's the worst of the worst
vampire in the history of vampires there
are multiple but man the annoying
henchman that's what really good snow
there's a Dracula you just punched him
in the gut and then the best is they do
a pun here at the very end ghoul luck Oh
Mary Kelly how big is this like 10
kilobytes or so like 15 I don't know you
can fit a JPEG on the right exactly
let's put it back in for thank you so
much breaking a museum because it makes
us feel a lot better about how do you
this xbox 360 and yes I well that was
the thing I asked you if you had a
master destiny like we need dig one out
I was like I was all set to order a new
master system and buy new ones mean
order mash them all right so I having
played Ghostbusters and forever okay 25
years so you better completa for the big
thing of here we go well what there we
go my name's g j oh well good enough i
count it got it throw it be in there I
don't know money well over the business
world see now here's the thing about it
is everybody thought this is a
Ghostbusters game the David Crane he
said it was a business simulator because
you have to go through and decide how
you spend your money then buy stuff and
go out see the sports car it's you
wanted the sports car da of course
because you wanted to get there as fast
as possible you're going calls here okay
this isn't you just get in there and
you're successful ghostbusters you got
to bust your buns to make sure you're
the best go special but of course
everyone's day after one yeah i'll buy
that for right now it's like the
cheapest one with a lot of them right
now you got to go through you gotta buy
look at this this is a lot more than you
thought there'd be wait wait why do you
have a cherry bar forklift you got a kid
it out these things are you know on top
of when your knowing grant your name or
I think that yeah they didn't watch the
movie to be like oh that's what we gotta
do here this thing's must be huge okay
so ya see now here's the thing people
forget about the Ghostbusters game right
is that all I got put this in the car
sorry you go through and right you're
doing all this the whole point was you
are we this is I don't don't get ahead I
don't want to steal anything from here
or this is the first dark souls was the
first diamond saws of games because
you're going to lose your first round
okay what you do is you lose then you
get an account number you enter it in
next time you play you come
back with more money you're kidding you
start with more money so you can keep
buying us got a new game plus our first
game plus the only game plus whatnot
yeah watermelon seeds of ya see and this
was of course the big thing to me as a
kid of just being like first off I don't
want to drive a sports car I gotta John
sports car yeah secondly none of this
crap looks like the Ghostbusters
graphical yeah you a super an ion beam
is that even in the thing no okay oh god
you can't fit that in all right honey
I'm bad at math everybody I didn't go by
and see a math video game all right
defensive walls and walls yeah what you
saw walking we're gonna get our ass
handed to us why am I even trying Zuko
going there what's the ghost base oh
that's how you get the LCL bring it on
you because we had to go out on the
streets my ladder these guys got it also
scare off the guilt you'll see it's good
there's a lot going on I had a boat and
additional women for the Apple 2 GS is
came in on like everything i think was
broken okay I that I was terrible at it
I really could not succeed or any
endeavor now again Greg Miller is not
played Ghostbusters in a long time and I
the d-pad doesn't work just the analog
stick go up Ghostbuster just go get this
baby Beluga Ghostbuster in the corner
yeah ghost in the core are you doing a
vehicular homicide on that pedestrian oh
I gotta get to the red thing that's
right that's where the ghost is oh how
we get to go out now we gotta drive ok
we're going to this call you doing 40
close mapping your GPS right oh yeah
what was ya what exactly was that
jewelry figured that technology my about
a decade is this part of the game or
loading i under control ok this is 100
Oh get away from me ghost man oh wow
again an accurate representation the
streets near rusev trauma unit of New
York alright so we got to go here if I
remember I don't know what the one in
two buttons are but they're there should
be a way to toss I bet I don't have the
money for it because eventually you can
bust the ghosts are coming in ok so here
we go now I got drive by busting right
now we're too late see isn't this game
fun can my god [ __ ] you the original be
even sold next see what's gonna happen
is I can't
these guys get to zoom okay I make zool
there we got put down the ghost month
date and now I drop on my buttons but do
what try and be a party is what's what's
book okay okay and then you get a guilty
rail bit press all of them all right mo
ya go here we go alright we're back on
the road all right there was gonna be a
ghost here unless I get another fatal
car accident I kinda like yards I
thought there was a power up you all
right here we go you're burning through
staff at the moment oh man yeah that's
how that's what if we make the final
thing where you gotta fight stay puft
yeah actually I'll just a horrible
against drunk driving as these people
swerve wildly back and that's how they
do it what's going on I don't have any
of the stuff to boston with oh yeah I do
no that's the vacuum okay uh what are
you doin right over I mean ok here we go
Slimers I'm gonna put our why that is a
lot of lime review here and I move you
here no was the great not a beer and
then we we walk together I think that
you gotta make them into across the
street make them into a call you write
the back of the box yeah okay so yeah
okay Oh got it ladies and gentleman the
original Dark go to the little bit
though all right here we go all right
back in the car I every time give us a
little insight into how you feel right
now it'd be feeling good I'm feeling
really good you are busted my only
problem is I cannot walk come on I think
that was a little bit of light purple
are the ghosts all right there let me
get the ghosts are they ever not out on
the street is known inside your ears
this is this is like you ever see gangs
of new york your are there pulling from
that continuity where people only died
in the streets you like a Holly's I
don't remember these ones oh you got
mall and we weren't getting riddle yet
slime always dead slime to death he died
on the job and you know what slime looks
like all fun and games but until it
floods your lungs in your fixie eight
Seaver oh that and if I touch them okay
go I can't get up kick it up I blame the
xbox controller as always what are all
you gotta like tapping me I can't endure
freeze them cuz if they have enough get
into the zoo
that starts the endgame that's happening
no matter what then of course you got
keymaster you're trying to like get some
more money right so you can go to shop
there gear up some more so that you're
prepared to take on the king of all
ghosts how would you have how long does
it take to inflate this bad boy if you
would like how to really what I was
doing good yeah I don't know I was a
damn kid I don't know do you have no
identity traps you got to go back
Ghostbusters HQ and how did what I don't
want i have no traps how'd you see I
read it at the top of the shine have you
ever completed this yeah well you have
okay okay it's at the end you I didn't
do it as a kid when I first get it I can
never get a god damn it now now looking
New York dri-eaz Louie sir I can start
next it I can see why they call it mad
men oh god the AMC's Mad Men no set me
or no two girls two brokers come on yeah
stay on message here yeah I think me I'm
getting better driving it if I got 20
kilometers to go next I don't think New
York is this big I don't think you're
going that fast either and I was right
in front of their Ghostbusters HQ and
this is actually in westchester county
they have to save some money you'll pay
to be driving at a kilometer second the
truth this is a one-for-one recreation
that's treating you it's the first open
world game yeah yeah oh you're getting
new stuff I murder or other ones oh all
these peeps are getting into simple but
if she can't city time energy jobs why
is this pixel perfect how many of them
have to get in before upon she's at pke
me energy stuff up there I think it
matters is there any points of the
people walking around yeah there is that
Rick Moranis Italy wondering exactly its
key master there walking around
gatekeeper keymaster yep eventually they
go to Seoul to that's when this thing
gets real man who can do it oh come on
there we go come oh yeah rubbin is racin
about right guys jerk off hmm I just
came in at 84 I believe it was an Atari
game first yeah and then this was a
Porsche I got pulled over there
this one I love Heather box was just
literally the logo that was the cash
donate a man of the ghost plus seconds
day that's what you needed all right so
put the one there and my control Charlie
you thank you put it up put them up pull
up hey wait come on yeah shoot yeah
we're out means doubling Joe oh my gosh
I'm really dead getting spit-roasted by
ghosts the worst way to go we're nearly
a bad time for this if you want to get
those guys to watch it all right I'm
gonna duel okay I think if I let him go
they power up Jules that right everybody
I'm remember that I'm sure yeah why not
whatever does the damier don't goin yeah
PKE meter is filling in TK energy meter
can we talk about what a brilliant game
this was given a bad impression of not
being able to go right and left it's
pretty good it's okay Nick a man in 1994
don't block them oh I'm talking to let
her sorry I was that's like you're jus
just I was impressed that I can finally
turn really I see light that can turn
the whole city is popping off right now
know the beat them don't want the help
oh you got no no it's gotta get ready
man we owe this day both we're gonna go
get him now he's up frozen right now
marshmallow alert when loud oh god an
entire city block while you stood by and
watched I would have taken me four years
listen there um I'm pretty sure that
this game claims you can you get to get
closer than anyone's ever been to the
ominous marshmallow man oh you haven't
seen it if we were like four city blocks
as long as this game doesn't end with us
just failing in the city destroyed which
I'm not sure if it's a possibility
because I was so good as kid we're gonna
swear you're gonna get closer to this
marshmallow than you ever have before oh
he's just murdering everyone Wow cute
this is awful have you seen Godzilla no
not yet so guys out of town last weekend
I really liked it yeah Bobby is it's
polarizing they're saying yeah they I
mean me you talking to people yeah yep
uh are you going to it expecting a
monster movie you're gonna get a fun
monster movie okay so you know you know
saying it's not the causing cultural
commentary that people have been looking
for in their monster movies ah no I
would say that is not the case we're
nearly there we go we got no bars nearly
full if that changes business MIT this
this meter changes purple
yeah wow yeah yeah he is a smoking ruin
I think those sources may be the most
popular game on the stream today this is
the best whooping signs coming up but
that's not invest based on the best
property mall time this is it here we go
now I if I'm right they yeah see look at
the game keymaster they're making a run
for it now here we get to go if I can
make it past [ __ ] Shakespeare not
Shakespeare sustainable freshman oh no I
screwed it up all the yeah well there
you go corsa Gore's indeed no wait this
reason yeah no you couldn't even set
foot inside it because you're unable to
earn enough money to gate in bitince
that's right what is that if you got a
good money so you can gain admittance to
fight the girl to save the city ok that
is over that's why again from the start
that's cannon from the movie you
remember because if you didn't have
enough money earned by the end of
ghostbusters yeah you had to tip the
bell man can't Greece's pockets forget
he knows make mean isn't he said this a
high-class establishment